hello this is mark Walton for GameSpot
and you're joining us to check out and I
am joined by warrior of Sparta famed
youtuber and community member thank you
very much you can see us here on camera
we've also got two people beside us as
well I've got Simon Mann the designer
for the game hello there
he's these are like some disembodied
voices you can't see and we've also got
James given who's the community director
as well a coordinator even yes hello I
see you didn't put the difficulty of it
all so you saying the Hans were speedier
was it slower the fast recovery they'll
have light cavalry no real armor they're
quite kind of mobile as it were as the
Romans will have the heavy armor so they
can't move as quickly and they tire
quicker right okay cool right okay so we
can do so we'll try and use we're gonna
try utilized obviously the schema shakal
we've got put them on the flanks trying
used obviously the heavy cover we've got
as well try and hit those sort of size
of the Eastern Roman Empire move into
that hammer and anvil sort of tattoo
you've got and try and see if we can win
the day obviously I mean this mode is
basically just set you straight
no Garth is just action action action
yeah we can't just put you in a kind of
scenarios at where I'm at you play out
so you can see the Hunnic forces are
much faster than to actually outrun the
kind of forces that coming at them from
the Roman you know like watching this
sort of stuff it like there's a lot of
Fanta clicking going on and everything's
happening very very fast so let's soak
it in it's kind of a nature of the huns
because they're not really kind of
forming a line and fighting like the
Romans but they're really look after
lots of different situations going on
the battlefield but also keep moving and
try and stay out of the range of
everyone because if you go well you
design these battles or a lot of them
also with a lot of the units now we have
a tier system so a lot of the units are
kind of early on and your campaign will
be like tier ones and as you go for the
technology tree you'll be I get tier two
tier three units but those units
generally a bit more upkeep sooo they're
the kind of like the core of your army
they're your best troops that you'll go
to and your tier ones will be kind of
more to your levies and so on so the
Tier one unit so all busy levies and
they're much more likely to break in
fights and they you have to keep them
around you general to keep them in the
fight and the tier 2 and tier freeze
generally are a lot more disciplined or
a lot more able to survive Roman forces
for example generally have a discipline
trait so a lot of our troops arrival
will stay in the fight no matter they
will break definitely if I hit hard
enough but they won't flee as quick as
I'd say the barbarian units just Phyllis
I mean your strategy here what's going
on I'm trying use it the flank get the
Covey around the back of him try use
that sort of hammer anvil to try to hit
pick off the infantry from the rear now
so we got to go to the gap here pull
through so you've made it much easier
for units to actually specially cavalry
to break away from combat as well so
it's much kind of easy for you to
actually do these hit and run back right
nice charging about there say what I
heard you only use it for cover mates of
protocol the seven pull back out again
use that shot cavalry advantage there so
also the interesting thing that's going
on here is as well because the Roman
troops are moving around so much they're
gaining fatigue yeah
when trees are running around the
battlefield they get tired when you're
tired you take massive penalties to your
actual combat ability and in order to
kind of restore fatigue you've either
got to be walking or actually at a
standstill yeah so basically the kind of
nice thing you can do as the hunt is
actually tire out the Romans so oh right
I get them they're so tired that they
can't actually fight back properly that
classic tactic back in the day it's
fairly classic time yeah and also
units can recover quite quickly compared
to its own rom - if you if you if you
ran around quite a bit the penalty of
fatigue would stay there a lot longer
and
come up a lot more often if you kept
moving and it's not quite the same until
you kind of can get it back a lot
quicker so it pays time but kind of
tactic of no gettin engage pull out a
bit rest of it then get back in where
before it would be almost consistent
consistent penalty of always being
fatigued and yeah the honey commies and
the nomadic tribes generally kept the
civilized nations because they picked
off as has been designed before and
obviously this heavy infantry of the
Eastern Roman armies they've if held
well and they're starting to break away
the middle the middle start to fall a
little bit here Simon what did you say
the historical battle this was based on
was you actually won in that battle I
don't think you probably started losing
until you reached cool that's right okay
started going a bit wrong but yeah so
kind of the hunting forces here have
kind of been a little bit cut off
oh dear oh that might actually be heat
so the people at home may have happened
is there is a fire
actually nothing we can do leave because
we may catch fire it stopped
false alarm I thought I would say it
then wow that could have been that could
read or quit valiant yeah well there you
go I was my first taste of ionic
gameplay got any difference I do dad
what need 500 more man they lost more
than me
but put a plaster impression right yeah
their strength prevailed in the end I
think we'll move on to a campaign now so
you actually have a look at a home
starting position yeah
the air was filled with smoke and blood
the hands glory din the stench of death
they took what they needed and left
their enemies - what
our hands were free they rode and fought
and lived fear built Roman rules they
were right to be afraid
and behold a Red Horse and power was
given to him that sat thereon to take
peace from the earth those with gold
offered it by the wagon the Huns took it
and allowed them to live in fear at
least until they returned
the writers of the Four Winds prayed to
him of the eternal sky they made ready
for war
the world will dance to your tune or it
will burn all right right okay so um get
back on top
so go back onto here so we've got
survived the following date for 100
these are sort of our first chapter
objectives
okay are various objectives okay that's
fine that's fine so we've got to survive
until 480 we would get 2,000 gold reward
for doing so easy right
no should be okay should be okay so
we've got two hordes basically I'm
correct yeah
three three we got old god rest we've
got one appears well yeah there is nice
now you're saying before Siamese it's
really important to try and keep
together with this don't spread too thin
so yes so because you've got no
settlements to hide behind you're really
vulnerable you know in order to key
itself strong you're gonna group
together as much as possible however
you're also going to suffer penalties
for being grouped yeah so the hordes
have kind of they kind of in fight when
they get near each other right these are
all people of different cultures so as
soon as they knew each other they're
going to start kind of fighting over
food and stuff if they're in the same
province so you gotta be a bit careful
with keeping them kind of too near each
other
sure sure Malaysian see who we are war
with what's his stance here so we've got
the did nobody is here okay say yeah
like no one was like no I've got too
many friends I don't think we've got a
few actually over here so I'm gonna look
very searching what we can do here so
we've got warriors camp which will
enable that building off if we research
here so it gives us research rate of 110
percent and there was a burning of
warrior camps and we've got this of the
permanent migration Society so both of
them will give us a locking of new
buildings so I'm thinking possibly where
there's been a migrating faction I think
these will probably be more central at
the moment to try and help with the food
income yaki
of all armies so I'm gonna go for the
Civic research estar with if you if you
bring up your campaign map and you click
on fertility you'll be able to find good
areas to go for yeah and you can see
they're like going into Greece and so on
there's just lots of green areas that's
where you want to go yeah
also don't forget when you move your
hoards when you've got about quarter
percent movement speed to encamp them
it's one of your stances yeah if you do
that you'll still gain some money and
you'll get more growth as well so in
camp focus on that quite a bit when
you're moving yeah okie-dokie right
that's fine bring these guys around so
with those two I think they income and
state there's two little move arrange
left okay that's fine
well these are guys gonna be on the more
the frontier the moment anyway so we'll
look to crouton here build from the land
and see what we can do I think you're
trying to look at probably raising an
agency-wide African once we've
researched them try and see what we can
do with those guys well you'll find with
the family trees especially so actually
affectionately do you kind of want to
keep them active all the time you want
to have him doing things I were fighting
in barrels or being a governor and if
you have him as a general and he doesn't
get involved in fights very often by his
other leaders do their own influence
will rise and they'll start to look at
the throne thinking I can do this and
you need to use your king to do things
otherwise yeah people within the tribe
or or your faction probably don't think
he's so good anymore yeah - you know
what the family's becoming more powerful
civil wars could strive and swear it's
worrying when he dies in front vowel
massive power vacuum and if a faction
isn't so good or has had the same
treatment of not doing anything it
really can cause a lot of problems and a
lot of the time with a lot of other
factions you're constantly kind of on
the edge you've got the climate change
you've got other factions walking
through your territory you've got
massive empires I'd the Western Roman
and incessant hoods
and especially if you're one of the
minor factions at the beginning you know
the death of your faction leader not
only can cause civil war but also can
have other factions looking on right
thinking now is an easy target but how I
mean how likely is that to happen I mean
do you have it's quite a well I really
you you need especially with tier 1 and
earlier units you need your general
around all the time to make sure your
army can stay in the fight
and because the general unit will be so
powerful he will be the unit that can
swing an outcome of a fight so you'll be
throwing them in there with just as much
chance that he'll die yeah and your army
run but you have no choice right
sometimes right I think we can do no
more on this turn so we'll end it we
always start off that's how it war games
trying to be kind of historically
accurate but with game player mode right
so the actual family tree of the time is
fairly accurate so when you start the
game you get an accurate tree um we have
tiller being born nobody knows quite
when he was born because born in the
period where we kind of think he came
along and but in general than that we
let the so many variables in play and
also we don't want to force the player
to play history this is about you doing
your thing as it were it's about you
changing history and making your own
story out of the characters that are in
the family tree it's kind of like my
favorite reason the family tree is back
yeah because it's like there's stuff we
tell you right we try and give you
tidbits a storyline bout see the real
story is what you write in between the
lines is it where if you know what I
mean like yeah of course I come up with
those situations yourself this elements
already been sucked
yeah it looks like it has buddy probably
got Astrakhan take my little things it's
it's literally the most vulnerable
settlement in the entire game yeah it
just goes down straight away okay here
they come right away the sunning out
towards me right I think the civilians
will kill all your men when the army
because they know you're leading in
they've already seen you in the fields
Oh attack taking down out draw them out
and then we'll move in on a couple of
flunks and then that should be pretty
much done I think yeah unfortunately for
the defending force first of all is
slightly depleted because our settlement
has been sacked recently and also most
of his armies made up of horse archers
and they don't have any range to use
them so so pretty much just gonna get a
shot out so they've got to come forward
otherwise they just sit there and die
yeah but the the finger you see on the
battlefield I mean if warrior zooms in
every so often you should see civilians
in the fields and the cities they'll run
away from troops and their lore so
sometimes pluck up the origin in games
know what's there outside so we've got
seeds excavation so the longer you see
Joe Salman now this probably isn't such
a big concern on on some of the -
ailments but when you've got big sellers
like Rome and Constantinople
you're probably not going to be I'll
take that with just siege artillery
alone you'll probably want to bring
ladders but what you can also do is by
seating the salmon for longer you get
different period different stages of
siege escalation so be see damage so
walls we crumble in more areas the gates
might be a low weak
but also resettlement self takes damage
so the more damage the settlement takes
the less
and relate a fancy house so it's not
easier to attack a settlement if you
siege it over a long period of time this
is not going to be oh please please put
your horse arches on to flame the shot
and start burning some buildings for me
yeah I need to warm my hands on this
okey-dokey see what you can do there we
go that's burning
come on Esther don't forget it spread it
out as much as possible yeah you can set
the whole thing on fire go for it power
you know honey I was trying to run
strong against the line of barricades
that hey just if here we go what can you
zoom in when you yeah yes we're gonna go
down now
well this is gonna be a file is gonna be
horrible for now
instant damage to Selma and the fire
arrows and because you also captured a
majority of shellman this garrison
forces do not stay very long if you do
that much kind of damage plus you were
also fighting against a Christian
faction so you've already got 10 plus 10
minus 10 roll due to scourge of God yeah
so that against Christian factions
especially garrison forces you'll
probably do away with them quite quickly
field armies a little harder because
obviously you got your faction leader or
or whatever a general leading force Wow
so we've got a lot of heavens every
infantry units which is to say the
eastern Roman Empire
we're classic for we've got look at this
body gone general cavalry with then
final day infantry cavalry aren't they
so so infantry generals so yeah this is
going to be it well they said what I can
try and do is Simon said if we can try
and utilize my skirmish akov try and
exhaust them down there maybe maybe this
is Alden himself this is our faction
leader this is our King oh okay
so if this guy dies right now well I've
actually I'll come in take the take the
reins but we don't want to lose it's
very bad we don't lose a new related era
ruger but of course the tiller himself
will come along at a later point in the
game and yeah he can become your faction
heir as well right okay so we're going
to take the high ground now we are on
the edge of the map as well which could
help is in some way no okay maybe
redlining it over here but we're gonna
try and sit back with these guys here on
this top of the hill here try and see
where the enemy come from utilize the
cavalry effectively use that Hill
advantage and charge don't I give you a
counter strategy or anything but all
those armies were coming in separate
yeah so it's four separate stacks which
is kind of standard for the eastern
Roman Empire and the western and
assessments is you have a load of small
armies which
times of trouble you start recruiting
more troops and mercenaries and then go
out and fight kind of like firefighters
you know you put down the little
problems in certain areas and you get
bigger whenever you need to
reinforcements and because you have a
lot of cavalry you could do a good job
of picking off two or three of these
armies on the way in yeah but that boat
might have already sailed
as you can see they're gonna try and
group up as a massive group and kind of
fight you in that kind of traditional
Roman style of just grinding you over
the inventory and they do have a lot of
skirmishes so you want to be careful you
want to you want to chip away at any
cavalry they have and then try and you
know separate those skirmishes from
heavy infantry yeah I mean it's really
important to remove their range support
they're gonna be your big weakness you
don't really have shields on your units
apart from your spear infantry so your
cavalry are basically sitting ducks to
anyone throwing a javelin for example
this is one of those situations they
were the man how much advice you give
with the horse armies it becomes very
difficult to really tie them down and
it's you end up just chasing them in a
lot of cases and eventually you have a
lot of infantry as the Huns as well you
gotta have a mix in a way you can have
this kind of vanguard which is like pure
cavalry and they can hit and run and do
a lot of damage but you will have at
some point type of mercenaries or levies
that you take from your client States
and they'll be the kind of like they're
the guys you're gonna send into the
breach when you try and take
Constantinople or when you try any wall
sitting yeah because you need that like
whelk and fodder basically and your
cavalry you're never gonna be cannon
bother there's some bestman criticism
here on the switch chair as we're bomb
that is but okay what was the point of
that charge at the enemy back with the
general and then Institute our gate
change of archers and then withdrawing
without even connecting everyone's our
general exactly
you know it's really hard to kind of
obviously like do this yeah and remember
every little thing we can get done
exactly yeah Oh close to feed though
yeah yeah Oh easy pretty well their
numbers obviously in the end but yeah
it's it's it's so hard when you in in
this in the actual mix of it all and
that's oh my god try to deal with it but
yeah so so what you've experienced here
is you sent one of your hordes which is
maybe your strongest one yeah but
unsupported and now obviously a lot of
people were looking at the Eastern Roman
Empire in the Western Roman Empire is
very high-profile targets of a lot of
money to take from writing and sacking
and so on but these aren't passive
empires these are still massively strong
and very rich and they can field huge
armies yeah and you will feel that very
early in these campaigns if you try and
take them on early on they will wreck
you where in the last 15 minutes of the
stream what do we think we should do
okay okay I don't know whether we'll
actually make it there but it's
certainly a goal that we should try all
right with one army we've only got 15
minutes make it these guys are not gonna
make it even for you this is more than
even fine what did you learn from the
previous power might help you in this
one well basically what can you do well
yeah as you say Simon said that the
infantry are the weaker ones try and
pull the cavalry out a little bit
quicker utilize that sort of shock
cavalry element but it's a try and sort
of not little like too much an inventory
to hold that centre because I think
that's what was happening before and
also flaming arrows are really useful so
if you have any skirmishes left
do you yep I'm like so far away from the
screen
yeah like they're all horsemen to me
what's your general was special ability
Riley that's a good one sometimes you've
got things like reconnaissance so you
can see in the Pacific area what's ahead
of you yeah then you've got like charge
bonuses rally obviously and and loads of
other things like fear fear which is if
anyone who played Rob to fear was by far
one of the best abilities to prick but
you can just make huge chunks of the
enemy army run away so when you see a
unit's icon flashing like that that
means they're almost broke and it's
probably the time for a cavalry charge
so that was surely is it I think so I
think they still got some units left
yeah I think you killed one army there
was two armies in this so you attacked
this smaller one there was a second one
in the woods oh and because your
attacker
you've already wiped out the one they
were planning to reinforce and now
they're gonna stay on that hill in the
woods so yes to it yeah take two they
knew to fight on five minutes to take
Constantinople yeah I don't think we're
gonna make it to Constantinople sorry
sorry not sorry sorry chef but hey look
you check it out when the game comes out
thanks so much for joining me today and
thanks to everyone in the room here and
there's lots of people here thank you
hello hello thank you thanks for
watching at home if you want to check
out more from Rome Rome what am i doing
total war Tiller
then check out GameSpot we'll have some
cool videos up soon and I believe the
reviews will be out real soon as well
meantime see you next time
you